الحاجه زبيده حكايه اراده سيده تخطط
الثمانين من العمر حرمت من التعليم ولكنها
لم تستسلم فالتحقت بفصول محو الاميه
وتعلمت القراءه والكتابه والحساب ونجحت في
الامتحان
[موسيقى]
في قريه صغيره بمحافظه المنوفيه تعيش الحج
زبيده ذات 87 مع شقيقتها بعدما توفي زوجها
وتزوج الاولاد والاحفاد اهميه الرحلات في
الحياه والافراد التعليم كان حلمها منذ
الصغر ولكن والدها لم يسمح لها وكذلك
زوجها وبعد وفاه الزوج بخمس سنوات قررت ان
تسعى وراء حلمها
اروح المدرسه والراجل قال لك ممنوع خروج
المراه بره تعملي ايه
[موسيقى]
في في المدرسه نحو قلت لهم تعالوا يا
اولاد انا عايزه اروح ده انا نفسي اقعد
على تختي
اول سؤال سالته لها طيب انت عايزه تتعلمي
ليه قالت لي عشان العلامه عز
قلت لها طيب تحبي ان احنا نجيب مدرسه
تعلمك هنا في البيت لان طبعا المدرسه تبعد
عن البيت هنا حوالي كيلو ونص قالت لي لا
انا حلم حياتي ان انا اقعد على تخته فما
تحرمنيش من الحلم ده قلت لها لا طبعا مش
هنحرمك لما اتعلمتي تقري وتكتبي بقيتي
بتقري ايه بقى يعني يسهل لك ايه في يومك
ليه لو انا في مشوار اعرف الشارع ده دخلته
ايه وخرجته ايه
زبيده جذبت انتباه القائمين على مشروع محو
الاميه باصرارها وبهرتهم بثقتها في نفسها
يوم الامتحان لقيت التثبيت دخلا اللجنه
شباب غير عادي
داخله ماسكه القلم بتاعها في ايديها ماسكه
الرقم القومي بتاعتها داخله عارفين الورقه
ورغم انها ردت لرغبه زوجها ولم تتعلم الا
انها حرصت على تعليم اشقائها واولادها حتى
انهو تعليمهم الجامعي وعملوا بوظائف
مرموقه انا عايزاك تقولي لي ليه صممتي
تعلمي ولادك
لا والبنات حتى البنات علمتيها والصبيان
علمتيهم كلهم الاربع بنات تعليم عالي
[موسيقى]
الحاجه زبيده قصه سيده بسيطه الهمت
الكثيرين حيث ترى ان العمر لا يجب ان يعيق
الانسان عن تحقيق ما عاش يحلم به سمر بشات
لصباح العربيه من المنوفيه
[موسيقى]